some neppo babies have been walking the
red carpet with their parents long
before they were walking in Solo here's
a look at some celebrities with their
famous parents in their earlier red
carpet picks versus their most recent
this is ble Danner and gwenneth palro in
1985 and here they are together again in
2017 this photo of Ethan and Maya Hawk
was taken in 2013 here's the
fatherdaughter duo again in 2023 here's
a photo of Diana Ross and Tracy Ellis
Ross photographed in 1995 and here they
are again photographed in 2019 this was
Zoe Kravitz and Lenny Kravitz in the
year 2000 and here they are again in
2020 and finally here is Victoria and
David Beckham photographed in 2001 with
their oldest Brooklyn Flash Forward and
here are the beckhams on the red carpet
in 2023